congratulations we're now at the end of
this course we're so proud of you it's
been great to have you with us all this
time you're well on your way to building
great applications that run in the
Google cloud but guess what we're going
to be launching more courses about the
Google cloud platform so make sure you
look out for those but in this course
you also saw how to build a mobile app
that can talk to your google cloud
applications talking of mobile apps
we're going to be launching a course
soon on how to build an Android
application so make sure you look out
for that one but before we leave you
just one final thing you have now seen
what you can do with App Engine today
let's have Ernest her slip a senior VP
of infrastructure at Google tell you
about the future of the Google cloud
platform so we're back here with Earth's
in this course we learned a lot about
that Benjen earth what can we expect
from google cloud platform an app engine
in the future a lot of innovation
because what I'm really most excited
about is that we're just at the
beginning of something and I think is
going to be really big you know we're
proud of what we have today but what
we're really aiming for is getting to
something that five years from now is so
much better I think the rate of
innovation that we're going to see in
that clown is going to pick up and we
hope to be a big part of that but our
goal really is to take what we have and
make it so much easier to scale right so
much easier to program so much easier to
be on mobile so much easier to analyze
data and then really get a good at get a
platform for you that is everything that
it is today but much much better really
to the point where if you remember what
you thought was great today we really
have a great product that you know five
years from now you kind of remember and
saying wow you know I'm kind of I was
naive to think that this was great
because if I look at today's product it
you know was really just the beginning
of it that's what I'm most excited about
do you have any final words to the
students that have now learned a lot
about App Engine now that you know App
Engine you're actually in a great
position to try out other parts of our
platform
and one of the things that we're really
going to work on is make it very easy to
combine App Engine with VMs or with
bigquery or with storage so that you can
mix and match and implement your
application not just in pure App Engine
but really combine it with any other
part that we have in our infrastructure
and still have it be very easy for you
to both right and run that's the path
we're on and I hope you enjoyed App
Engine and you'll enjoy the other parts
even more that's right we've barely
started on this great journey to build
google cloud applications so keep your
coding fingers up to date and stay on
top of what's possible in cloud
computing because day by day the Google
cloud platform gets better and better so
you can be sure that you will always
build the best applications when you run
them on Google infrastructure see ya